>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Colleen Shogan: So welcome
to the sixteenth annual
National Book Festival.
On behalf of the Library of
Congress and all of our donors,
I'm very pleased to be here today.
My name is Colleen Shogan.
I'm the Deputy Director at the
Library of Congress of National
and International Outreach,
the unit that takes care
of the National Book Festival so
we're very excited after months
and months of work to be here today
and I'm joined by two gentlemen,
two authors that really
need no introduction,
but I'm going to try
to do it anyways.
Newt Gingrich is the former Speaker
of the House of Representatives.
He the author, co-author of over
25 fiction and non-fiction books
and his latest book is
a page turning thriller
that we're going to
talk about today.
And Congressman Steve Israel
represents the third district
of New York and previously
had an anthology of one
of the greatest wartime speeches
and his latest book
is a political satire.
So, please join me in
welcoming these two guests
to the National Book Festival.
[ Clapping ]
>> Colleen Shogan: So,
we'll start out just talking
about your most recent books.
Speaker Gingrich, can you
tell us about "Duplicity"?
>> Newt Gingrich: Well, we wanted
to set out to explore the tension,
for example, between
loyalties and so,
"Duplicity" really has
three parallel tracks.
One is a member of the
Somali community in Minnesota
who is running for Congress while
his brother is the number two leader
in Al Shabaab in Somalia,
and you have all the tension
of a family split between those
who have become modern and American
and those who have rejected America
and gone back to be terrorists.
Second, we have the
actual adventure in Somalia
in which we have a marine officer,
and african-american woman,
who is directly engaged in
very difficult situation along
with the head of the CIA
station and that's sort
of a pure action, classical thing.
And then third, we have
a Presidential campaign
in which the incumbent President
has made the decision to prove
that they're tough on foreign policy
by opening the embassy in Somalia
against everybody's advice and
it blows up and then you get
into the sort of underlying,
do you really tell the truth
even though it might cost you the
election or do you find a
way not to tell the truth,
which actually runs parallel to some
of the things that's
in Steve's novel.
So, Steve and I in
some ways are dealing
with very different angles towards
the same dilemma of a free society
that finds transparency
a little difficult.
>> Colleen Shogan: And can you tell
us about "The Global War on Morris"?
>> Steven J. Israel: I
will Colleen, thank you.
You know there's congressional
courtesy.
There's also author's courtesy.
Colleen is a great author...
>> Colleen Shogan: Thank you.
>> Steven J. Israel: She's written
some thrillers about Capitol Hill
and the word thriller and Capitol
Hill don't really belong together
in the same sentence, but I
commend your attention to her books.
My book, "The Global War on Morris"
is a parody of Washington, D.C.,
the White House and Congress
and it was based on truth.
I was elected to Congress in
2001, 2000 starting serving 2001
and I immediately found
myself, tragically after 9/11
in the most classified settings
you could imagine the President
of the United States and the Vice
President and so I had perspective
into the thinking and the dialog
of our nation's top leaders
and how you respond to terror.
And several years later I
happened to be at a hearing
of the Armed Services
Committee, where I learned
that the Federal Government,
and this is consistent
with Speaker Gingrich's writing,
that Federal Government had
accidentally spied on a group
of innocent elderly Quakers
in the state of Florida.
And I had my plot.
Now, I know nothing about innocent
elderly Quakers in Florida,
but I'm an expert in white Jewish
men in their fifties on Long Island
and so I invented this
character, Morris Feldstein,
who is non political,
hates watching the news.
He just likes watching Met
and Turner Classic Movies.
Mr. Speaker, Atlanta.
And for some reason he is
believed to be a leading terrorist.
So it is a story of what happens
when a completely innocent
human American is believed
to be a major terrorist
and I tell the story
through the prism of
parody and satire.
Rob Reiner is trying to develop
it for film, but I've learned
that giving a famous
Hollywood producer an option
on a book is the functional
equivalent
to a bill being referred
to committee.
It just languishes forever
and that's where it is.
>> Colleen Shogan: Let's talk a
little bit about Morris Feldstein.
He's a pharmaceutical representative
who becomes a national
terrorism suspect.
The first time I read
your book, I thought well,
this was a tire happenstance of
circumstance, all these bad things
that happen to Morris Feldstein.
Then, the next time I read the
book, when I was getting ready
for the book festival, I thought
maybe Morris made some bad decisions
that inadvertently led to some of
the things that happened to him.
So, can you comment on that and
tell us more about the genesis
and how you view Morris Feldstein?
>> Steven J. Israel: Morris
is a completely innocent
apathetic character.
His wife Rona is very involved.
Very engaged.
She has a crush on Wolf Blitzer,
but Morris, like all of us,
occasionally makes a mistake.
He may have visited an
internet site unwittingly
that the Federal Government notices.
He may have had a conversation
with somebody
who he doesn't realize may
be a person of suspicion.
And through the entire series
of accidents, of coincidence,
of innocence, Morris Feldstein is
believed to be a major terrorist
and the story is about how the
entire Federal Government just comes
down on this poor guy who can't
understand why every time he goes
to work there are helicopters over
him on the Long Island Expressway.
>> Colleen Shogan: Speaker
Gingrich, talking in keeping
with the character
development, you mentioned one
of your very interesting
characters, Captain Brooke Grant,
your book moves from place to
place and storyline to storyline
from different points of view, which
is actually very difficult to do
as a writer because you have
to keep it all in your head,
but tell us about Captain Grant.
Why you came up with that character?
It's very unusual to have a heroine
in a thriller and are we going
to see her in future books?
>> Newt Gingrich: Well, working
backwards, yes, you'll see her
in a book that comes out in October
that's called "Treason" and I think
by that stage she's a Major and
her career is semi prospering.
We want to do a couple things and
we talked about this in length
and I have to say that this
particular book was written
with Pete Earley who
is a terrific talent.
He used to work at the Washington
Post and has written a number
of books in his own right
and we would really sit down
and really try to think through.
So, we started from an
outline because we have
so many parallel threads that you
really have to have some sense
of how they're going
to fit together.
It's like sort of building
architecture before you start laying
the foundation.
And part of our discussion
was that we wanted
to represent the complexities
of the modern military.
So, we wanted to find somebody,
and the Marines are normally
assigned to Embassys.
So, we wanted to find somebody who
would represent the change over,
which is very real, in
which you would have a woman
in a position that's
potentially in combat
and in this case her
parents had both died in 9/11
and so she had a real
vested interest.
We also tied her back
into the power structure
because her father's brother,
her uncle, had become Chairman
of the Joint Chiefs and there's
a tension between his desire
to not let her get in
danger and her determination
to be treated like any other Marine.
Although, nobody knows going
into it that Somalia's going
to blow up the way it does.
By the way, in doing some of
the research for some of this,
if you go to Australian Foreign
Ministries website they very
explicitly say, do not go
to Somalia and remember
that the airport is a high
value target for the terrorists
because it's where people like
you who are really stupid go.
I mean we were just reassured that
nothing had improved dramatically
and we weren't writing about
something was implausible.
>> Colleen Shogan: You have
written all kinds of books,
as I mentioned in your introduction.
You've written some
historical fiction,
I believe that writing thrillers
is a new endeavor for you.
Do you have any particular
influences?
Why did you decide
to write a thriller?
Are there other thriller
writers that you like to read?
>> Newt Gingrich: Well,
we've written some very
interesting fiction books,
both straight historical fiction,
three volumes on George Washington,
for example, and then
alternative histories,
one of which we have Lee winning
at Gettysburg and then walk
through permutations for two more
volumes of what might have happened
in a post Gettysburg
Confederate victory kind of world.
And we did a Pearl Harbor which we
had Admiral Yamamoto come forward
and lead the raid as the
greatest Japanese aviation leader.
So, we've done that kind of
stuff and I've been approached
for a number of years to do
something that was contemporary,
but I didn't feel comfortable
and the more I got engaged
in studying terrorism and it's a
funny thing because our two books
in a way are really both
pieces of the same problem.
In that Steve is giving
you a cautionary tale
about the security state's ability
to get totally wrong and to do it
in a way that you as an
individual are almost helpless
in competing with.
I'm trying to get across
the idea that that's true,
but by the way there
really are bad guys.
And the bad guys actually
tend to lie
and that our politicians
are stunningly short sided
and I'm can say this
having been a politician.
All the pressures of the
system are on this morning.
I once spoke to a very sophisticated
National Security Advisor
who had a very deep training
in all this stuff and I said,
so what's your strategic plan?
And he said, it's the front
page of the Washington Post.
He said, I get up in the morning
and that defines how we're going
to spend the day and so we want to
indicate that when we make decisions
in that framework, and they start to
go bad, particularly if it's close
to an election, everybody
has a pressure to lie.
And it's not particularly Benghazi.
You can go back through the last
five Presidencies, there are plenty
of examples of that underlying
pressure to say the thing
that will get you through
the election even
if you know it's totally wrong.
>> Colleen Shogan: Talking
about writing style,
when I read "The Global War on
Morris" I was really reminded
of the writing of Christopher
Buckley.
You have a very witty, humorous,
laugh out loud at times
writing style.
>> Steven J. Israel: Thank you.
>> Colleen Shogan: Tell us a
little bit about your influences
and how did you develop
that writing style?
>> Steven J. Israel:
Well, let me just comment
on something the Speaker said.
He said he's no longer a politician
so he can say certain things.
I have to wait until January fifth
when I'm no longer a politician
to say the same things.
So invite me back next year.
>> Colleen Shogan: Ok.
>> Steven J. Israel: I was very
much influenced by Carl Hiaasen.
I think he's...
>> Colleen Shogan: He's here.
>> Steven J. Israel: He's here?
>> Colleen Shogan: He's
here at the Book Festival.
Unfortunately, I think
at the same time.
>> Steven J. Israel: Oh.
I'll see you guys later.
Christopher Buckley.
One of the great thrills in writing
the book, there were two thrills.
Well three, Speaker Gingrich said
he enjoyed the comedy in the book.
Bill Clinton called me, I was on
the road one day and I got a call
from Bill Clinton and I thought,
oh my God he's going to grill me
about some race in
Arkansas, I was the chairman
of the democratic national
campaign committee.
He's unhappy about
something and he got one
and he said, Steve,
I love your book.
That was the second thing.
And the third was I got an
email from Christopher Buckley
who had read my book
saying he enjoyed it
and he encouraged me
to write further.
But the guy who really influenced
me the most, I have to say,
is an author named Nelson DeMille.
I don't know if all of
you are familiar with him.
He's just wonderful.
He happens to be a Long Islander.
The John Corey series, "Gatehouse",
"Lions Gate", "Panther" and I got
to know him and I just loved his
style because he writes thrillers,
but with that kind of comic
overtone to it and I said Nelson,
I'm thinking about writing
this book, what's your advice?
He said, well if I
were you I would one,
don't quit your day
job, stay in Congress.
Two, get plenty of alcohol.
Lock yourself in a room and
don't bring in any weapons.
And he helped mentor me
during the writing of the book
and he was very, very helpful.
>> Colleen Shogan: Well, speaking
of that, you wrote "The Global War
on Morris" when you're a
sitting member of Congress
and that's a pretty busy job right?
We can all agree on that.
So, how did you fit that
into your day to day work.
Writing takes time so
how did you manage that?
>> Steven J. Israel: I
wrote the entire book,
and I know this seems implausible,
I wrote the entire book on what used
to be my Blackberry and
then my iPhone in real time.
So, I would come out of a
briefing with President Bush,
Vice President Cheney, obviously
I wasn't allowed to bring anything
out of the briefing, but I would
just kind of write my impressions
and the dialog that I heard and
then when I would see something
or hear something I
would just start writing.
Planes, trains and automobiles.
I would wake up every morning
at five, write for a couple
of hours then go to work and then
during some Congressional committee
meetings, depending
on who was testifying.
>> Colleen Shogan: Speaker Gingrich,
you're not in Congress
anymore, but you're very busy.
You're a political consultant
in political communications.
When do you find time to write?
>> Newt Gingrich: Before
I answer that,
let me say what you'll find
if you read these books.
His understanding of that part of
his constituency is extraordinary
and if like me you have not grown
up surrounded by aging Jewish,
males who are intimidated
by their wives,
the whole thing is a
revelation, the way he writes it.
And this is one of the keys
to these kind of books.
It has the ring of
such authenticity,
that it's really remarkable
and I think it makes it a
very, very intriguing book.
I mostly write on airplanes
or we take cruises occasionally,
I'll write on the ship.
But it's a little bit like Steve
said, I tend to write episodically
when I can get around to it and I
have the virtue I write very fast.
Callista will tell you I don't write
very well because she edits a lot
of my stuff and it's accompanied
by a lot of painful noises.
I write very fast and I can edit
very fast and so the key thing
to me is, there are two things.
One, when I was very young, I wrote
a book called "The King of Paris"
which was a biography
of Alexandre Dumas,
who was the second most popular
French novelist of the 19th century.
And when he was young
somebody said to him,
live life until it's overflowing and
then write, and so part of it is,
I've studied history, I've
lived a little bit of history.
A lot of things I can
write about very fast
because they're already in my head.
The second part of it is, I find
thinking harder than the writing.
So, getting it in your head.
When we did Gettysburg, for example,
we got the Army warcologist experts
and went out for three days,
walked the real battlefield,
then we developed an alternative
battlefield and had people
who had really immersed their
lifetime in understanding that
and that's part of what we do.
We went out to Minneapolis and the
sheriff was very helpful and we sat
down with a whole group of Somali
community leaders and talked
about the pressures in the
community and what they worry about,
what's happening and so forth.
So, we tried to build
that sort of thing.
I spend time with some people who
had been in Somalia for Black Hawk
Down so over the years, so
I had a pretty good sense
of Mogadishu and that sort of thing.
So, you piece together all those
things and then I agree with part
of what Steve was saying, it's
really helpful to write like crazy.
Don't get too tied up in parsing it.
Just get it out of you and
then you can start editing.
>> Colleen Shogan: Ok.
A question for both of you.
How much of your fiction
writing, if at all,
a proxy for your own
political beliefs?
Or do you tend to keep those two
things, like I do, very separate?
>> Newt Gingrich: In my
case, it's 100 percent.
I mean I'm writing about a
world that I worry about.
Whether it's about the
alternative histories or Washington
or the current problems
with terrorism.
So, for me, whether I'm
writing non-fiction or fiction,
they're actually parallel
because they're didactic.
I'm trying to communicate messages
that I hope people will take
seriously and will think about.
>> Steven J. Israel: I
write from right to left,
not from the Jewish perspective, but
from the ideological perspective.
So, my writing is left of center,
but I was cognizant as I wrote
"The Global War on
Morris" that this had
to be an equal opportunity offender.
So, I actually take on President
Obama in various points in the book.
There are quotes in this book from
President Obama, and so I tried
to make sure there was some balance
and you know frankly I'm just
putting a question out there
and that is, how does the
government get it right
when the pendulum swings
from protecting our security
to protecting our civil liberties?
What happens when the
government gets it wrong?
And I think that that's
a question that is
in fact a bipartisan inquiry.
>> Colleen Shogan: Ok.
One last question before we
open it up to the audience.
Two parter.
What are you writing now?
What are you working on right now
and do you have a new
book coming out soon?
>> Newt Gingrich: Well, the book
we have coming out in October is
"Treason" and actually
what we're working on now,
plus in addition to
books, I do movies.
We just finished a documentary
on Washington called,
"The First American" and we're
working on the first phases
of a documentary or potentially
a multipart series on women
in the American Revolution,
which is really interesting
and a much more powerful
story and has been told.
So, that takes up a lot
of our creative time
and then we frankly run Gingrich
Productions and do 25 other things.
>> Colleen Shogan: Ok.
>> Steven J. Israel: I am almost
finished with a manuscript to Simon
and Schuster, it's similar to
"The Global War on Morris".
It's a political parody
about the gun debate
in Congress called "Big Guns".
>> Colleen Shogan: Ok.
Terrific. We'll look
forward to that.
If there are any questions
from the audience,
we'd be happy to take them.
There's two microphones
situated here on the aisles.
>> Hi thanks.
I liked "Duplicity", though
I must say that I did not
like the heroine a little bit.
I think she's a little bit
too snarky, but she was brave.
I wondered, the woman
President, was there anything
about the Hillary campaign in that?
>> Newt Gingrich: There wasn't,
but we really wrestled more
about whether or not to have a
woman President than we wrestled
about to have a woman in
combat because we thought
that that would lead to that and
it's not necessarily Hillary and,
in fact, I don't know that Hillary
would behave very much the way we
had President Alworth
behaving in the novel.
But again, we wanted to
portray a moment in time
where an incumbent President
felt they had a real challenger
and took steps to knock out the
real challenger and the steps blew
up in their face and now
they had to figure out how
to handle the last six
weeks of the campaign.
And I think that's a very plausible
scenario no matter what the sex
of either, the challenger
or the incumbent.
>> This also for you
Speaker Gingrich.
You wrote about a strong
african-american woman.
How did you go about being able
to write from her perspective?
What would be your research in doing
it from such a not you perspective?
>> Newt Gingrich: Well, I don't know
if I should resent that
implication or not.
We talked to a number of people,
particularly in the Marine Corp,
and the longest serving
teacher in the senior military.
I've spent about a quarter century.
My dad was a career
infantryman in the Army and so,
I have a very wide
range of contacts.
We were also careful because
we wanted her to be a person
who was very determined
to be a professional
and this has been my experience
when you talk with the vast majority
of rising younger women
in the military,
particularly in the officer
corp. I mean they're in there not
to be judged as a woman and not to
be judged as an african-american.
They're in there to be judged
as a professional and you find,
for example, in the Marine
Corp a very deep sense
of cultural esprit de corp and we
tried to communicate that sense
and her unwillingness to back down.
Her unwillingness to be relegated
to a secondary role by various guys,
most of whom are less
competent than she was.
>> Thanks for the time.
This is a little bit more
of a political question.
So, I apologize, but for both of
you, I actually got into politics,
volunteered for a Congressman
and Senator about ten years ago.
I thought things were
really bad back then,
they seem to have gotten a little
bit worse, especially I'm going
to say on the polarization front.
So, you go onto Facebook or
Twitter and it's sometimes you open
up Facebook and you
close it down again
because you're like
I don't need this.
And I'm wondering what
you guys think
from leadership positions
in respective parties.
What's driving this
rigorous political
[ inaudible ]
. This has been going
up and up and up.
What's driving the
polarization at root?
What can you guys do about it?
Do you think it's a problem?
I mean and what should we
do about it as individuals?
>> Steven J. Israel:
Here's my experience.
Several years ago there was
a Republican Congressman
from Springfield, Illinois
named Tim Johnson.
Tim Johnson and I, understanding how
polarized the Congress had become
and how polarized the country was,
created the House Center
Aisle Caucus and we would meet
on Monday nights at the Hunan
Dynasty Chinese restaurant
because cheap chinese food
is something Republicans
and Democrats can agree to
instantly and this is what we'd do.
So, I use this as an example
and then I'll tell you
quickly what went wrong.
We would have a timer and
set it for five minutes,
pick an issue, healthcare.
Five minutes, state
your disagreements.
Fifty five minutes
what can you agree on?
It was the most liberating
experience I've had in Congress.
Twenty five Democrats,
Twenty five Republicans.
After two years, the Center
Aisle Caucus was almost defunct.
Members had to leave.
Why? I believe because of
Congressional redistricting
on both sides of the aisle.
There were 435 Congressional
Districts in Congress.
I'm the former Chairman
of the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee.
My job was to elect Democrats
and defeat Republicans.
I can tell you, the true number of
competitive Congressional Districts
in the country out of 435,
maybe 60 if that much.
So, if your Congressional District
has been drawn to the far left
or to the far right, you wake up
every morning in fear of a primary
from the far left or the far right
and that divides the
Congress to the extremes.
One of the smartest things we can
do in my belief, is to find a way
to have non-partisan redistricting.
Draw districts back
towards the center.
So, members of Congress
are incentivized
to compromise rather
than to polarize.
[ Clapping ]
>> Newt Gingrich: Yeah, I guess
I'd make two very different points.
The first is, intense
polarization is not uniquely 21st
century behavior.
If you go see the musical
"Hamilton",
you'll notice that the Vice
President shoots the Secretary
of Treasury.
And we haven't had
that happen in years.
Yeah, so I start with the
idea that this is a very rough
and tumble country and
politics, Dick Gephardt,
who was a Democratic
leader when I was speaker.
Dick and I used to
talk about the fact
that politics is how
we sublimate Civil War.
Politics is about dreams,
passions, ideals, interests,
money and there are really
big differences that are real.
They're not just made up by things.
I think the one where I
guess I would be skeptical
of Steve's solution, is
if you look at the Senate
where they're elected
statewide there's no
[ inaudible ]
. The Senate is at least as
deadlocked as the House in terms
of partisan and I think
that's in part
because the divide is that real.
I mean if you look at the
underlying polling data right now,
the gap between a hard
line Hillary person
and a hard line Trump
person is a really big gap
and it's reflected in
the two candidates.
And remember in some ways to
Trump's to Cruz was in some ways
to Trump's right and certainly
Sanders was in some ways
to Hillary's left, so the potential
gap could have been bigger.
Not smaller and I think we're
in a process as a conversation
as a country that could easily
take 20 more years to sort out.
If we had really smart it could
take four to eight to twelve years,
not very smart it could take up to
20, but we've had very difficult,
now, I'm not being a Pollyanna.
Charles Krauthammer asked me one
night why I was fairly comfortable
with the risk of Trump
and what was going on
and I said, well I'm a historian.
Compared to the American
Civil War, this isn't bad.
He said, that's your standard?
>> Colleen Shogan: Terrific.
Next question.
>> Mr. Speaker, first a comment.
A lot of people write about the
Army and I appreciate your writing
about the Marine Corps
in your most recent book.
>> Newt Gingrich: Let me point
out that as an army brat,
there was a certain
pain in that decision.
>> Secondly, take you
back to the 90's.
A book you wrote, "1945".
Are there any plans for any
type of sequel in the works?
>> Newt Gingrich: You know,
Bill Fortune who was my coauthor
for that, "1945" was an alternative
history in which for a variety
of reasons, Hitler does not
declare war on the U.S. We end
up only staying the
Pacific Campaign.
Hitler wins the European Campaign
and then things evolve from there.
We talk about it occasionally,
this is an interesting
insider book story.
I'd given a speech at the annual
Science Fiction Convention
on the importance of man's space
and the importance of breaking
out of the NASA bureaucracy and Jim
Bane, who was a wonderful guy came
up to me and said, you know I'll
pay you some money to you know write
about a book about all
these ideas and he did
and I wrote a small book called
"Window of Opportunity" which came
out in 1984, which discouragingly
is still fairly accurate.
We haven't broken through
on most of those fronts.
So, he came back to me, the
year before he became Speaker
and he said, I want you and
Fortune to write this novel
about alternative history,
so we did.
When I became Speaker,
I wrote a book called,
"To Renew America" based in course,
we're doing American Civilization.
And it began the number one
bestseller for it did very well.
And Bane suddenly got excited.
He has a little novel which has
nothing to do with public policy.
And is in the shadow of a number
one bestseller and he prints
like 200,000 copies
and I said to him Jim,
you know, so the book was a dog.
As his perspective as a
publisher it sold 30,000 copies,
which might have been
nice if he printed 40,000,
but you print 200,000
and he's eating them
as a little publisher, he's dying.
So, for years people said
Gingrich can't sell fiction.
When we finally got a
contract to do Gettysburg,
they printed like 25,000
copies and sold
out the second week
we're sitting there
because they didn't believe it.
They said, how does this happen?
So, all these years later,
fortunately I've looked at the idea
of trying to find somebody
who'd be interested in the idea
of publishing the sequel to
"1945" because it does kind
of have a cult following, and
it's just one of those things
where of all the projects
we're working on,
we've never quite had the energy,
but I suspect if a publisher hearing
this decides to rush up to us
that Bill and I could be talked to.
>> Well, hopefully.
Thank you.
>> So, one of the last
questions was about polarization
and about social media and my
question is for both of you.
Since both of you write books,
which most people my age don't
read anymore, how do you both
as politicians and as authors
thrive in this age of social media
where everything is
instant and built
to this very shortened tailored
sound byte, rather than a full novel
or book or complete idea?
>> Steven J. Israel:
That's a great question.
That's a great question and for
me the book was a form of therapy
because as a member of Congress,
when I go on any network,
doesn't matter whether
it's Fox or CNN or MSNBC,
I've got to make my
point in sound byte.
These days when you go to the floor
of the House of Representatives,
you get a one minute
speech, a one minute speech.
If you're lucky a five minute
speech, no more than that and so,
as a member of Congress, there
may be some of my colleagues here
and I think they would agree,
I found myself very frustrated
with the fact the we're dealing
with some of the most complex
and profound issues of our time.
Maybe in all of American
history and we've got
to boil it down to sound byte.
So, one the issue of the
balance between personal security
and personal liberty, this was my
way of really thinking about it.
Of exploring it and
not being confined
to a sound byte or
a one minute speech.
It's how I grappled with that issue.
>> Newt Gingrich: Let me offer
you a slightly different version.
First of all, don't they still
allow one hour special orders?
>> Steven J. Israel: Yeah,
but nobody watches those.
>> Newt Gingrich: Just as
a background for a minute.
My career began, I'd lost twice
in '74 and '76 and I arrived
in Congress and was sworn in
in January of '79 and in April
of '79 C-SPAN started and so I
became the leading user of C-SPAN
and because I used to teach college,
I thought 55 minutes was a
plausible length of time.
And so several of us got in the
habit, we would speak for an hour
and all of our colleagues would
say, nobody's listening to that.
Well the truth was that a quarter
of a million people were listening
to it in any given hour and so, I
would try to say to my colleagues,
how far would you fly to try to
talk to you a thousand people,
which is a big crowd if
you're a House member.
You know, they'd fly
all across the country.
I said ok, so you can walk across
the street from your office,
go on the house floor and reach
a quarter of a million people.
And one of my favorite
stories, Bob Walker was one
of the leading people,
he's from Pennsylvania.
And there was a group in Waterloo,
Iowa who were the Waterloo Watchdogs
and they were Republican women
and they would watch C-SPAN
and then they would all get
together over coffee and talk
about whatever we had just
talked about on C-SPAN.
And in this period, Jack Kemp
was the best known Republican
House member.
Kemp ends up in Puerto Rico
and says, oh my God, Mr. Kemp,
do you serve in the House?
He says, yes I do.
She said, do you know Bob Walker?
Suredly enough for Kemp
who was totally humiliated,
says I know Bob Walker.
But here's my point.
Abraham Lincoln could debate for
hours as he did with Douglass
and could also give the
most important inaugural
and the most important kick
off speech in American history,
both of which you could stand at
the Lincoln Memorial and read.
They're that short.
So, Lincoln would have done
fine in one minute units,
because he would have summarized
what he was going to say.
Now, he could also send up and
I recommend to you the State
of the Union address he sent
up in December of 1862 as one
of the great state
documents in American history.
He could also write extraordinary
deeply thought through messages
to Congress which were
aimed at the country.
The greatest single
political achievement
in American history is
Lincoln sustaining the morale
of the North despite the casualty
rate and despite the defeats.
And it's all done by the
ability to articulate in a way
that combines moral effect
with practical effect
so people decided yeah, I have
the pain, but we have no choice.
And if you want to really study the
genius at that level, study Lincoln.
In our case, we are enormously
helped by Christina Maruna
who leads our social media project.
We have like a million,
600,000 people on Twitter,
about 710,000 on Facebook and
we do from documentary films
to short things on Facebook.
We do lots of Facebook live,
some of which gets a couple
hundred thousand views
and then we write books,
so we live in a country
that if you're willing to,
there's an amazing number of ways
to reach people and let
them go through a crescendo.
You know, they get the one minute
version, the ten minute version,
the long article, the book,
the seven volume course.
I mean you can do all these things
and have a conversation,
but it takes times.
We're not used to the
frustration that maybe this kind
of dialog takes 10 years
rather than 13 weeks.
>> Colleen Shogan: Ok.
Next question.
>> Yes, good afternoon Speaker
Gingrich, both speakers.
I was thinking you know,
all day, especially in light
of the different presentations
here today that the framers
of our Constitution had to
have in mind national security
and religious liberty as the
founding kind of modus operandi
and modus vivendi of this
nation or it wouldn't exist.
And in light of the security
climate world we live in today,
do either of you gentlemen
have a perspective on the role
of religious ideologies
and national security?
What's the casm?
What do you forecast for the future
of this nation given
that both climates are..
>> Newt Gingrich: I don't
think there's a contradiction.
>> Ok.
>> Newt Gingrich: And let
me draw the distinction.
This is a country that gives
you an enormous range of freedom
to be an atheist, to
have any sort of beliefs.
What it doesn't give you
is the right to attempt
to overthrow the government.
So, if you come into the U.S.
and I'll give you an example.
The man who built the car bomb and
it didn't go off in Times Square.
The one where he got his engineering
backwards and it fizzled and the guy
who was running a hot dog
stand walked over to the cop
and said that car is smoking.
And they looked at it and it
turned out it was a car bomb.
Well, he was a Pakistani, he
had gotten American citizenship,
he had gone back to Pakistan to take
an advanced course in bomb making,
much the way you might go to an
extension school or something.
He came back the U.S.
and he built the bomb.
He's taken to court and the judge
says to him, how could you do this?
You swore an oath of allegiance
when you became a citizen.
And the man's answer was
very straight, I lied.
You are my enemy.
I have a moral duty to lie to you.
Now, we don't today know how to
have a debate about what you do,
this is not in the sense that
you mean religious liberty,
this is not a religious opponent.
This is an ideological opponent
dedicated to the destruction
of the American system and you
have every right to defend yourself
against somebody who wants
to destroy your country.
And the fact that they happen to be
of a particular religion
makes it complicated,
but you can also divide that up.
You could say look, if you happen to
be Muslim and you're willing to live
under the U.S. Constitution
we have no complaint.
If, on the other hand, you
believe it's your moral duty
to replace the U.S. Constitution
and you're prepared to kill people
to do so, we have an enormous
disagreement with you,
but that's not a religious
liberty issue.
That's a national survival issue.
Steve?
>> Steve J. Israel: Very briefly,
I'm a right of center Democrat
in the United States Congress
on National Security issues.
I'm considered to be a conservative
Democrat on those issues.
I believe that our first
obligation in public life is
to protect the American people.
Keep them safe against all
threats, foreign and domestic.
We have been having this debate
since the Alien Sedition
Acts by the way.
The debate between national
security and religious liberty.
This is not a new debate.
It's a heightened debate, but it
is not a new debate and I agree
with the Speaker's perspective
that it has nothing to do
with what religion you are.
It has to do with are you
loyal to the Constitution
of The United States of America?
I took an oath to protect
and defend the Constitution
of The United States of America.
And if there's disloyalty, I
don't care what religion you are.
If you're perceived to be a threat
to the national security interests
of the United States government,
the government has a responsibility
to protect its constituents.
Sometimes the government gets
it wrong and goes too far.
Sometimes the government screws
up and doesn't go far enough
and that has been the essence
of our debate on those issues
since the founding of this republic.
>> Well said gentlemen.
As the widow of a veteran
and the daughter
of one I thank you for your service.
>> Steven J. Israel: Thank
you for your sacrifice.
>> Good afternoon.
This question is for both speakers.
When the contract with America was
introduced in 1994, Mr. Gingrich,
the only part of it that was really
enacted was the welfare reform
and whenever people talk
about it's success today,
they mention welfare reform
and it come to a full stop.
And I believe your contract
also included entitlement reform
and tax reform that would have
like caused some dislocation
among non poor people.
So, both speakers, why is it that
the only part the parties were able
to get together on was the part
that caused the dislocation
to the least empowered and
when are you going to come
to some bipartisan agreement on
some of the entitlement reforms
and the tax reforms that will cause
dislocation among the empowered.
>> Steven J. Israel: I'm
going to yield to you
since I wasn't there at the time.
>> Newt Gingrich: Well, I
actually participated this week
in a Brookings Institution
Workshop on the 20th
of passing the welfare reform bill.
So, let me start with that.
It's biggest single change was
to establish a work requirement
that was a very substantial
number of people
who left dependency
and went to work.
Their incomes rose.
We had the biggest decrease in
children in poverty in the late 90's
in modern history and most people
think it was directly related
to the fact that we required
welfare offices to shift
from being dependency offices
to being employment offices
and to focus on how they could help
people get jobs rather how they
could help people remain dependent.
So, that was that part.
We had a commitment
to a balanced budget.
The only four balanced budgets
in your lifetime came
out of the contract.
So, that was a fairly
significant change.
By the way, we did it
while setting priorities.
We doubled the size of
the national institutes
of health while balancing
the federal budget
because we thought research
into biology and into health was
in fact a major part of
our future as a country.
We passed everything
through the House.
We voted everything
in the first 100 days.
Actually the first 93.
We passed everything
except term limits
which did not get a constitutional
majority in the House and frankly,
the desire for term limits dropped
dramatically once we had won the
election because we proved to
people you could defeat incumbents.
In a sense, the election
of 2006 and the election
in 2010 had a similar kind of effect
because if you can beat
them you don't need
to worry about term limits.
Just go out and beat them.
And so I've seen three wave
elections in modern times, in '94,
2006 and then again in 2010.
>> Steven J. Israel: I
am retiring from Congress
and there are certain things that
I worry about long term and one
of them is entitlement reform.
Here's why.
We are facing a demographic crisis.
When Social Security was created,
within ten years of the creation
of Social Security, there was
approximately 40 workers supporting
every retiree.
Now, it's closer to two workers
supporting every retiree.
If you read the National
Intelligence Council's Quageneral
Report on what the world will
look like in the year 2030,
and the next report is coming
out describing the
world in the year 2035.
We're going to add more
elderly people to the population
of the planet Earth than
ever before in human history.
It's going to be extraordinary.
The good news is medical
technology will keep us alive much,
much longer than anybody
ever predicted.
The bad news is there is no way
that social security, medicare,
public pensions or private
pensions here or anywhere else
in the world can sustain
that population.
And so while Democrats and
Republicans need to continue
to find bipartisan accord
on national security,
they're also going to have to have
figure out how we're going to care
for that massive increase in
the population of the elderly
with respect to retirement
security and no matter
who wins the Presidency, I have
my own theories on the matter,
that is going to be the ticking
time bomb that either Mr. Trump
or Secretary Clinton will be facing
on the day that they are sworn in.
>> This question is for
both of you gentlemen.
How do you envision
a Trump presidency?
>> You took my question.
I was pretty close to that.
>> Steven J. Israel: I don't.
Mr. Speaker.
>> Newt Gingrich: That was a good
answer, but I'm not loving it.
>> Steven J. Israel:
Sound byte though.
Two words.
>> Newt Gingrich: I
think it will be, well,
I tell people to get some
historical perspective in Trump.
Combine the disruptive
patterns of Andrew Jackson
with the sheer physical
energy of Theodore Roosevelt
and the permanent salesmanship of
P.T. Barnum and there's something
in those three that comes together
and that sort of creates Trump.
If Trump wins, and I think the
odds are at least even money,
we'll know a lot more after Monday
night, but if Trump does win,
I think he'll be an extraordinarily
change oriented President.
I think that he will rely on his
ability to generate enormous waves
of public demand so that
his instinct will be to go
into Congressional districts and
have you know rallies of 40,000
to 50,000 people at a time in the
football and baseball stadiums
and he'll be capable
of generating that.
And that will get a lot of attention
from the members of the Congress.
You know, you get 50,000 of
your constituents somewhere,
you tend to listen to
the guy who did it.
Reagan, the best study of what
Reagan learned is a book called
"The Education of Ronald Reagan".
It was a little book that was a
study of Reagan at General Electric
and Reagan worked with a guy
who was the Vice President
of Employee Relations at GE.
He had seven unions.
Two were headed by communists
and five were just left wing
and all seven made demands that
would bankrupt General Electric
and you couldn't negotiate
with the senior leadership.
So, this guy, his name was Bulwor.
Bulwor actually built a
model of communication
to convince the members of the union
of what was economically sustainable
so they would not vote for a
strike that was irrational.
And he brought Reagan in because
he wanted a popular figure
who would be nice and pleasant.
So, Reagan went around the country
and gave something like 370 speeches
to blue collar workers at
factories owned by General Electric.
Back then it was a huge
employer of blue collar workers.
Reagan wouldn't fly.
He went through a period
from 1945 to 1965
when he wouldn't get on an airplane.
And so he was going around by train
and Bulwor's giving him all these
conservative economic texts to read
and Reagan learned the whole model
that if you could move the opinion
of the majority of the people,
that the political
leadership would follow it.
Now, they were doing it at GE to
get the union leaders to follow.
Reagan did it to the country.
Reagan's model was, I will show
the light to the American people
so they will turn up
the heat on Congress.
And I watched him do
it again and again
where he'd make a speech,
which is very
[ inaudible ]
, if you go look at
Reagan's speeches, Callista
and I did a documentary on Reagan
called "Rendezvous with Destiny".
Reagan's speeches have lots of facts
and they're designed to drive home
for you why you have legitimacy to
call your Congressman or Senator.
And Reagan could move the
county 20 or 30 points
with an Oval Office
address and people knew it.
He's very formidable.
Trump will use a variation on
that model, if he gets elected
and he will start with very
big changes in my judgement.
He will not come here to be one
more normal political leader.
He'll come here to pass very large
changes and will gamble the rest
of his career on being
able to get things done
with the American people
insisting that Congress pass it.
That's my guess.
>> Colleen Shogan: We have
time for just a brief question.
One last brief question.
>> I hate to do this,
but I have a question
about the debate Monday night.
My concern is is that
Donald Trump is not a policy
[ inaudible ]
. You have lots of familiarity
with policy and how do you coach
like Donald Trump to
be able to talk policy
with somebody like
Hillary Clinton...
>> Newt Gingrich: You don't.
>> Or how do you coach
him during the debates?
>> Newt Gingrich: Well, I'm going
to say and I do a brief commercial.
I do two free newsletters a
week at Gingrich Productions.
One of them this week
was on debate coaching.
And I describe both Hillary's
problem and Trump's problem.
And they're very different.
Trump is the fastest
debater I've ever seen.
If you look at the Republican
debates, there were 12 of them,
the elites didn't believe
he was very smart
and the elites didn't
believe, in fact if you watch,
I got turned on the very first
debate with Megyn Kelly, Fox hosted.
Everybody in the elite said Trump
lost the debate because he got
in a big fight with Megyn Kelly.
Callista and I were looking at
it and about midnight I began
to realize that on
Twitter and Facebook,
70 percent said Trump had
won, out of a field of 16 now.
Wasn't 70 percent of
Trump versus Cruz.
Out of 16 people, 70
percent were picking Trump
and I said, wait a second.
If everybody who's an expert on Fox
News said he lost and 70 percent
of the everyday people said he
won, this is about as big a gap
as I've ever seen and it
continues up into today.
Trump's strength is
sheer speed and the fact
that he's totally comfortable
with himself.
I mean whether he's talking
about the size of his hands,
which is the weirdest moment
in Presidential debate history,
or he's talking about little
Marco or low energy Jeb
or the 647 buildings he built on
Tuesday morning before he got up.
He's totally authentic and so
you're staring there fascinated
by this weird hair and this big
guy and he's bouncing around,
but he has lots of energy and he's
very comfortable and they're going
to ask him lots of questions he
won't know, so he won't answer them.
He'll make up his own answer for the
question he wishes they'd asked him
and the average person
will go that's fine.
Hillary's great strength is
she knows an enormous amount,
but she's not nearly
as fast as Trump is.
What she's going to
try to do is practice
and my guess is they've gone through
30 different debate variations
and they figure if he does A
you do B, if he does C you do D
and she's practiced every one of
them and they've videotaped them
and they've looked at them and
she'll be totally prepared.
The problem is, she's totally
prepared against a person
who you can't prepare against.
Well, is it going to be the
noisy Trump or the quiet Trump.
You know, it's going to the Trump,
because he's a counter puncher,
it's going to be the Trump, it
needs to be based on who she is
and he will evolve in
about four seconds.
So, whichever version
of Hillary shows up,
four seconds later the
appropriate counter veiling version
of Trump will show up and he
will do it almost seamlessly
and at home we won't notice he did
it and the challenge for her is,
if she takes him head on,
he will go right at her.
If she doesn't take him head
on, he won't take her head on,
he will be very respectful.
He really doesn't counter punches.
He doesn't actually go out and start
fighting, he just clobbers you.
Bill O'Reilly once said to me,
why don't these guys attack Trump?
And I said because Trump is the
grizzly bear in "The Revenant".
You know, you get his attention,
he gets awake, he comes over,
he bites off your face,
he sits on you for awhile,
everyone else in the room is
going not me, I'm not doing that.
>> Colleen Shogan: Well,
we've definitely heard a lot
of differences of opinions
today, but...
>> Steven J. Israel: This is why he
should have been Donald Trump's Vice
Presidential nominee.
>> Colleen Shogan: But, there's
one thing that we can all agree
on is these two gentlemen are
terrific writers and I commend both
of their books to you
so happy reading.
Thank you for coming
to the Book Festival.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov